this is where pawn used to be found
places where keeping children out it's
relatively easy now
pawns gone online and those barriers
have disappeared the government solution
looks a bit like this
it's demanded age checks for every UK
porn user and promise the scheme is
going to come into effect in less than a
month but will it maybe not because Sky
News has seen a confidential letter from
a lobby group representing porn firms an
age verification providers calling for
the so called palm block to be delayed
for the third time I showed the letter
to the lobby Goods chair Lord Errol
blames the regulator a hundred and seven
year-old sensor than British Board of
Film classification it's taken them two
years to get to this point
it was April 2017 we passed this thing
through Parliament and it's I don't know
what they've been doing for two years
but you wants an extra three month delay
only because of the certification scheme
that the BBFC have just produced and
they say they're not going to give a
stamp of approval to websites if they
don't pass they're very expensive
predictions when a certification scheme
is that a fair complaint experts say it
has been a tough ask it's a very very
difficult problem to solve which has
implications for the most sensitive data
that you might be sharing in the online
world so for us it's it's really good to
see that they are willing to delay in
order to get it right and yet Sky News
has seen a second confidential document
this time from the BBFC insisting that
an age verification solution must be
wholly separate from and distinct to a
digital wallet what this document from
the regulate the BBS team means is their
porn websites and age verification
providers don't have an easy route to
make money out of doing HX and my
sources tell me that that and not the
certification is really the key reason
for this dispute they wanted ways to
collect cash off users to offer them new
services maybe
to profile them who knows we warned that
this would happen we said that if the
skein goes ahead there is a large
temptation formula companies to try to
make extra money out of users data
that's collected sky sources say that
the government will delay the palm block
tomorrow
is this the end the delays in perpetuity
so make of that what you will run a map
top Sky News